[Music]
we are starting new year with good news
for home buyers Las Vegas realtors
association reports that home prices are
back to where they were a year ago
Madison Kimbrough joins us live tonight
with more on the latest report Madison
if it seems like new housing
developments are popping up everywhere
you would be right like this one that
right here by Spanish Trail you can take
a look we've reported how in 2022 it's
been a seller's market across the valley
but now according to Las Vegas Realtors
the market is more balanced which means
if you're looking to buy a home prices
are now affordable lvr reported that the
median price of existing single-family
homes sold in southern Nevada during
December was 425 thousand dollars that's
down 1.4 percent from November and
matches the median price from December
2021. that's also down from the all-time
record price of 482
000 that was in May of 2022. lvr
President Lee Barrett explains
it's actually what we call a balanced
Market a balanced Market is anywhere
between three months and six months
anything between six months and nine
months becomes a buyer's market and so
the benefit of the balanced Market is it
benefits both people benefits of buyer
benefits a seller
Barrett also stating that 2022 ended on
a much different note from 2021 which
was a record year for existing home
sales in southern Nevada but while home
prices are decreasing making it easier
for a potential home buyer the price for
condos and Townhomes are actually up by
about two percent that's from December
of 2021. reporting near Hacienda and
buffalo Madison Kimbrough 8 news now as
Madison mentioned the price for condos
and town homes are still up the median
price being nearly 250 thousand dollars